كامل
عمليات متسلسله تجري الان داخل
دراغون
وهذه المرحله الاولى
وسوف يتم تبريد المحرك لانفصاله تمهيدا
لانفصاله
عمليه الفصل تم تاكيدها الان
[تصفيق]
وهذه مهمه الاطلاق
هذه المرحله الفصل
التي يتم انجازها الان
الجانب الايسر والمحرك لا زال يعمل اثناء
مرحله الاطلاق
والمرحله الثانيه نراها على الجانب الايمن
من الصوره
وهي باتجاه الفضاء
بانتظار العد التنازلي الى حين الجاهليه
الاولى بصوره كامله
المرحله الثانيه تستمر
في مسارها صحيح
وهنا تتم عمليه الفصل 4 دقائق في
الانطلاق والامور تسير في نصابها ونرى
الان لكي كيف تجري عمليه الانفصال
في المدار
المسار الاخر
بالاثاره في
اخراجي
والان بدات بتشكيل نفسها وبدا
يه
[موسيقى]
الخطوات المطلوبه لاجراء عمليه الانفصال
من خلال فصل كبسوله دراغون متجهه الى
الجانب الشرقي من سواحل الولايات المتحده
بالقرب من بوستن حيث
تنطلق الاشاره من هناك
من خلال التعاون مع الفريق العمل استطعنا
ان نحصل على صور حيه لفصل الكبسوله
وهذه صوره اخرى للطاقم
وقد بدانا نسمع بان عمليه الاحتراق كما
ترونها على الجهه اليسرى من الشاشه قد
بدات للتو
وان نهائي عمليه الاحتراق تساعد على ابطاء
المركبه الفضائيه في الغلاف الجوي المرحله
الاولى هي عمليه جر اساسيه التي تعتمد على
التوصل الى سرعه قدرها 70% من اجمال طاقه
المركبه الفضائيه والان
نرى صورا جميله للفضاء على الجانب الايسر
وصوره اليسرى تظهر مدى الاقتراب من الفضاء
التي تحاول الهبوط في منطقه
وهي تحلق بما يقرب من سرعه الصوت
هذه صور تاتيكم من خلال كاميرات التعاقب
الخاصه بنا ونستطيع ان نرى الشبكه التي
تستعد
لخبوطها
بشكل كامل
ونحن بحاله استعداد الان
لاتمام المرحله الثانيه واكتمالها
التي يبدو انها اقتربت من الهبوط
يمكنكم ان تروا
ان
قد هبطت مره اخرى في المنطقه ال جي 1 من
خلال هذه المهمه الفضائيه
[موسيقى]
والعوده سوف يكون هناك
مرحله انفصال المحرك
حيث سوف تنفصل
بصوره كليه
نتوقع ان يتم انفصال سيكو خلال 20 ثانيه
الابطال
ووقف التشغيل
الاغلاق قد لمحرك الثاني قد تمت في
توقيتها الصحيح
وهذا ما يؤكد انفصال المحرك
ويمكننا ان نؤكد
نجاحها بنجاحها بصوره كامله
تم فصل النظام ونص
ونستطيع ان نرى الطاقم
باوقاتهم ويستمتعون
بما حققوه احد
الرواد رواد الفضاء المخضرمين الذي هو ضمن
الطاقم
المرحله المقبله سوف تكون هناك عمليه
الفصل حيث
هذه المحطه الفضائيه
سوف تنفصل عن المرحله الثانيه
بنشر مقدمه المركبه
بالاتجاه الامامي مع الفتحات مع الفتحات
الاربعه التي تستخدمها المركبه من اجل
تثبيت نفسها في محطه الفضاء
من اليسار الى اليمين
نرى ان رواد الفضاء يستمتعون في اوقاتهم
لدينا ريان برناوي
وعلى
يمينها الطيار
اليمين علي القرني
يمكننا ان نرى
الاجراءات الاحتياطيه
التي يحملها
التي يضعها رواد الفضاء على انفسهم
وهذه هي المره الاولى التي نرى فيها اربعه
رواد فضاء في ذات الوقت
ونحن بحاله استعداد من اجل انفصال دراغون
والتي يتوقع ان تحدث خلال ثواني القليله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
ترون على الشاشه ان الكبسوله قد انفصلت
[تصفيق]
وانها عمليه ناجحه للغايه
تحصل على الاوقات طيبه
اتمنى ان تستمتعوا بهذه الاوقات مع بعضكم
كطاقم متكامل
وتم تفعيل ادوات الدفع فيها بصوره كامله
عمليه التفعيل والتحقق منها التي لا تزال
تسير على قدم الوثائق
[تصفيق]
دراغون تسمعني اخبار طيبه
هناك
اذا عمليه ناجحه للغايه مشاهد تحبس
الانفاس في هذه العمليه نجاح عمليه
الاطلاق اذا كبسوله رواد الفضاء تنفصل
بشكل كامل لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات